how
everyone and welcome to today's poster
presentation protein X rapid assay
lateral sulcus for detecting protein
tags and antibody ISO typing presented
by krishna vadym senior RMD scientists
protein and cell analysis Thermo Fisher
Scientific I am Alexis Krause of lab
routes and I will be your moderator for
today's event
we are delighted to bring in this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by Thermo Fisher
Scientific for more information about
our club please visit
before you begin I would like to remind
everyone that this event is interactive
we encourage you to participate by
submitting as many questions as you want
at any time you want during the
presentation just click on the ask a
question box located on the far left to
your screen and type your questions into
the drop-down box that appears on the
screen or insert as many questions we
have time for at the end of the
presentation
if you have trouble seeing or hearing
the presentation please use the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
having a problem
this presentation is educational as thus
offers continuing education credits
please click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your credit
please join me in welcoming dr. Krishna
vadym I will now turn the presentation
over to him
my name is Krishna bottom I'm a senior
and a scientist at Thermo Fisher
Scientific today I'll be talking about
protect private as collateral flow kits
for detecting protein tags and antibody
Isis typing
so if you ever visited a doctor's office
for a routine flu test or have used a
pregnancy test kit you must have noticed
that the answers are really fast they're
accurate and these are instantaneous
basically you walk out of the lab and
then you got the result in the doctor's
office these tests are usually based on
a technique called lateral flow
scientifically speaking they use a
technique called amino chromatography as
the name suggests it's a combination of
chromatography and antigen antibody
reactions
someone's experience using these tests
but can assume that these are very rapid
sensitive accurate and easy to use
I forgot the use of this technique in
life science research is concerned these
asses have very little presence in this
posture will report Pro detect lateral
flow assays for using common protein
expression and detection workflows
providing valuable advantages over
current detection methods for rapidly
monitoring expressed of recombinant
proteins that have a purification or
detection tags on them
these assets we hope will address key
pain points in cell culture and protein
expression workflows by providing a
quick qualitative yes-or-no answer on
the success of protein expression
if one looks like protein expression
workflows as in this freezer there are
several points at which one would like
to know if expression is going on
according to plan or everything is going
on into plan at each step from the point
of growing the initial cultures to post
induction one would like to know if and
when the expression has started and if
it has reached a plateau
using to detect lateral flow assays one
can very quickly and at the point of
expression
okay right next to the cultures where
they are growing you can monitor the
expression of proteins
if proteins are secreted all you have to
do is collect the cells supernatant and
dilute if necessary using the dilution
buffer provided in the kit and you can
use a microfiber plate or a micro
centrifuge tube and just dip the
prototype strips into them and just wait
for 10 to 15 minutes and you should be
seeing your result very fast the
proteins are endogenous you can use in
your for lysis buffers that we provide
that we commercialize or even if you
have your own lysis buffer that's fine
too all you have to do know is the
composition of the lysis buffer and and
you can basically use that lysate that
you make and dilute it if necessary
in a micro centrifuge micro centrifuge
to by the microtiter plate and just
place the prototype strips into them
just wait for 10-15 minutes and you
should see as that
so so as you can see in this free room
and there are several points at which
one would like to know those expression
is going on according to plan or not
during induction during pre induction
post induction of proteins one can also
monitor expression of proteins in the
illusion fractions obtained from an
affinity column so you induce you grow
the selves you induce your lights or
cells you take the lights to put on
infinity column you collect the
fractions okay you can add the affinity
fraction column you can quickly monitor
the expression of proteins by just
taking a sample of the Aleut putting in
a micro centrifuge tube and just dipping
the protein text strips into them one
can only imagine the loss of time and
money if all you're doing is to just
monitor the UV rays at the end of
experiment and not knowing all along if
you have been expressing proteins at all
so there's a lot of value in quickly
detecting the expression at each point
of the expression purification work
flows
now the pro detect rapid acids you as a
competitor or the sandwich as a format
company devices are designed to protect
proteins that contain smaller tag such
as pista HT tag black tag sub tag and so
on the sandwich ass is on the other hand
are designed to detect proteins that
have larger tags on them for example GST
MVP sumo FC regions of antibodies like
human rabbit flat which can also be used
as tag purification tags
very briefly the architecture of the
lateral flow strips using competitive
essays as follows if we look at the
panels on the left side for a minute the
top half of the lateral flow strip is
where you will actually see the results
it positions indicated by the letters C
and T T stands for control P stands for
test line test line one test line two
and dash line three the bottom half is
where you will have gold conjugated
capture antibody conjugates which are
very specific to the analyte of interest
that you are trying to detect and this
is the bottom half is also the region
where you will actually dip this strip
the lateral flow strip into the sample
as I said before you can have a sample
in a micro set of plate or a micro
centrifuge tube
or any other of your convenience other
device of the convenience
coming back to the top half a control
antibody is immobilized at the control
line indicate but letter C
which will appear both in positive and
negative results this is just to say
that yes the chromatography is working
as planned the liquids are flowing from
bottom to the top
the target analyzed an analyte sorry is
immobilized on the membrane as three
distinct test lines as I said before T 1
T 2 and 3 T 3 these are the analyzed
actually impregnated into the numbering
now come to the actual how the results
looking part in a minute but this kind
of format is only specific to the
competition as is you'll have a control
line and you have three test lines well
how do the results look at the end of
about 10 to 15 minutes of incubation of
this lateral flow strip into the
solution
in a negative result in a negative
result where no analyte tagged protein
is present in your sample or the
contouring concentration of the tagged
protein in a sample as well below the
detection levels
the goal conjugated captured antibodies
which are in the bottom half of the
strip but actually migrate to the top
and will bind to the analyte positions
t1 t2 t3 which will result in the
formation of three red lines so in a
sample which does not have the analyte
you will see the test lines lighting up
in a positive test on the other hand
whether sample contains the target tag
tag proteins the gold conjugated
antibodies will bind to the tag proteins
in the sample instead now and therefore
will not bind the test lines upon the
top
as a result
test lines do not appear so very briefly
the sample has an analyte the test lines
will not show up the sample does not
have the analyte test lines will show up
the concentration of the tag protein in
your sample increases the number of test
lines will gradually decrease and even
sugar disappear
the concentration of the tag proteins is
inversely related to the number of test
lines appearing on the strip
now moving to the sandwich asses so
sorry I was just going to go back to the
slide previous slide if we look at on
the right side tweedily website this is
just an example to show that the sample
which contains a big pack protein the
test lines actually disappeared
if there is no Mick tag protein that pre
test lines appear this is to the right
side of the slide when you see sorry
coming back to the sandwich asses
which rather philosophy
or concreted captured antibodies which
are presented bottom half of the lateral
flow strip are very specific to the
target analyte and these are embedded in
that region
okay and additionally there is one more
antibody called a detection antibody
which is present again which is which is
which is also specific to the analyte
but at a different typical so in this
sandwich acid conditions you have two
antibodies one is gold conjugated and
impregnated into the conjugate pad and
the other antibody is impregnated at the
test line so both anti Saudis antibodies
are specific to the same analyte but
raised they can difference every
different epitopes so upon application
of the sample that has analyte present
you know the intensity the LM is in the
light of interest is present in a sample
they capture antibodies
bound to any present analyzing samples
travel along the length of the membrane
and are resolved as two lines test line
and the control line and at both large
and both these lines start lighting up
this is exactly like a pregnancy test
kit where one one line showing up means
do not have positives or the two lines
show up that means it's a pass result
the sandwich has is exactly work like a
pregnancy test kit if as I said before
if there are no band displayed at the
test line that means the sample is
negative
so the control lines here do appear both
in a positive and a negative s
indicating that the assays working as
planned so the sandwich is very easily
to relate to a common si out there in
the market either in the doctors acid
doctor's office or in the pregnancy test
kit as I said before look at the example
on the right we try to detect GST tag
put in the sample and the two strips
that are present there in a negative
sample which is indicated as none
there is no GST in the sample only one
line shows up in a positive result
whereas GST is present in the sample two
lines are lining up when is it the
control line as I hit the test line so
these asses that extremely simple to
read and to analyze just remember
sandwich assays presence of line in the
test line indicates the sample is
positive for the analyte a competition
si on and other hand disappearance of
the test line indicates the presence of
the sample the analyte in the sample
sorry
now we have a number of kits in the
market so these are either broadly
categorized into a competitive or the
sandwiches as I said before sandwich
asses are designed to detect larger tag
like a sumo GSD MVP and the FC fragments
of human rabbit and mouse the
competitive assays on the other hand
designed to detect smaller tags H a step
back to every tag McVie fly we have one
more one more kit it's called a dual tag
detecting kit detects both the flag and
the hash tag but this one works in a
sandwich format so you have to have a
dual tag on the protein with this and H
a on either end or at the same and
doesn't matter but the assay works in a
sandwich format where appearance of the
result at line at the test line
indicates success of presence of analyte
in the sample success of presence of
doers act in the sample
but if you look at just a flag or just
the hips just individually they work in
a competitive format
um again talking about the range of
detection ideal range of detections
sandwich asses are very sensitive when I
love sandwich answers because they are
very sensitive that it can detect like
the ideal range is 0.12 10 microgram per
ml that we recommend where the signals
are really strong but you can also get
signal where the concentration of the
protein is for example 10 nano gram per
mil in subtidal nanogram per ml as
indicated here you can also see 10
nanograms per ml detection and you can
also see proteins which are in the range
of 100 microgram per ml but the signals
are slightly weaker that's why we
recommend being 0.1 to 10 but if you are
outside the ranges that is also fine
signals are slightly weaker in a
computation as they on the other hand
ideal range of detection is 4 to 20
micrograms per ml anything about 20
microgram per ml the signal just is
disappeared completely disabled which
means there is no upper limit for a
competition acid anything beyond 20
micrograms ml per ml a signal to count
indicates the presence of the protein
your sample anyways do not worry about
it
anything below 4 micrograms per ml
sometimes it's really hard to say but I
would not recommend somebody going below
that my program but for detecting
smaller tagged proteins so between 4 and
20 micrograms per ml it's a nice
ingredient of disappearance of the t3
test lines the each of the test line
will have different concentration of the
analyte in it as a background but as
increased go from 4 to 20 micrograms per
ml gradually the each of the line
disappears and beyond 20 micrograms per
ml all the three test lines disappear so
next slide the next two slides we're
going to show two data data application
data using a prototype kit in this slide
which you're looking at it right now
we compared the sensitivities of a comb
a sustainable staying gel versus a wesen
blood versus our protector GST as a
stress as you can clearly see DSD our
prototype strips are detecting proteins
as let us point one microgram per ml in
this example here but as I said before
even if you go point zero one microgram
per ml you will still see a signal so
these are awesome these are extremely
sensitive sandwich as it gets down to 10
nanograms per ml or or five nanograms
per ml even it in in some cases you can
clearly see that when you do a crisis
day and everybody knows you've got to
get a stain you verity strain takes
anywhere from two to four or nine put
your lesson plan the same issue it can
meet you're gonna go grab the antibodies
you got are going to do the left turn
you can just run the gel transfer
primary secondary wash you know you can
do all these steps it takes anywhere
from four if you're fast enough to all
right
protein tech strips fifteen minutes max
and you should see a result it extremely
fast and accurate now we're not showing
a ton of data that we are generated here
it is in includes specificity of these
steps how specific these are and and how
accurate these are in terms of cross
reactivity or in terms of seeing any
other background proteins from lysis
they are very clean these steps that is
a very specific all the data is put on
the website or you can also see some of
the data posted in our IPs
so this is one more example here how we
use the pro detect kids to just look at
whether we are successful expensive
protein or not this is an example as I
said before the two ways of looking at
Express protein in cells one is if it is
secreted no problem just take a
supernatant del you'd it in the protecta
as a deletion buffer and you just dip
the strip into that and you should get
your result in 15 minutes the protein is
endogenous which is most of the cases in
this case - as well as the one two
testing right here the we expressed a do
attack protein to contains flag in the
head and this was expressed in a
bacterial cell the cell the protein is
inside the cell we had to quickly take
about our microliters of the cell and
light for about five minutes take the
supernatant and then quickly dilute in
our dilution buffer which is about a
micro liter of the lysate or put 5
microliters of the like sale to detect
the expression of the dual tag protein
as you can clearly see is at 3 panels
that you're seeing right there
the left panel is the dual tag protein
detection kit for flag and test which
works like a sandwich assay can clearly
state 1 and 5 microliters you can see
the signal showing up in the middle
panel which is specific for the flag you
can see that 1 & 5 microliters the
signal disappears which is also
indicating the presence of the protein
in the head alone steps which is on the
right side the tail is at 1 and 5
microliters the signal also disappears
okay so you can use these kits very
rapidly at the point of need either in
the cell culture room next to the
wherever you're trying to express your
protein and not just that as I said in
the beginning slide you can even take
your illusion fractions coming out of an
affinity column and quickly look at
whether your proteins being a looted or
not whether the Peaks are coming out of
the UE trace or really your Peaks your
the put that contains a protein of your
interest so one thing that you have to
also pay attention is the the background
of these lysine buffers we provided a
extensive information on what are the
limits of potato genes
that you can use
in your system ideally you know if you
dilute your sample all the effects most
likely disappear anything that is coming
from a high SDS or higher year or
whatever be the can high detergent
conditions these effects will really
minimize if we dilute your sample if you
do not dilute the sample you have to
know the limits of how much is allowable
and that's published in our instruction
booklet as well
so in conclusion product X rapid si
rapid a circuits are really quick easy
sensitive acids that can be used to
analyze the progress and progression of
protein expression and purification the
pro tect rapid IC is an assistant
decisions for go/no-go at every step of
the workflow you don't have to waste
hours and days of time and then at the
end of the day you see oh my god I
didn't express a protein what I was
doing all these days you don't have to
go through the order type in that those
kinds of pain you know and these assays
are compatible with a lot of commonly
used component slices and buffer
solutions as I said before all the
Ecuador is what is exactly the
composition of your lysis buffer and as
I said before these assays have been
also characterized and made sure that
the background from the bacterial yeast
and mammalian cell lysate do not
interfere with these acids so in short
these are extremely powerful and rapid
assays and please definitely you should
try these assays and let me know if we
have any question I would love glass or
any question that you have thank you so
much for your time
you
Thank You doctors Adam for that
informative presentation we will now
start the live Q&A portion of the
webinar if you have a question you'd
like to ask please do so now just click
on the ask a question drop-down box
located on the far left to your
presentation window type your question
into the box that appears on your screen
and click the send button
well inserts many of your questions as
we have time for so let's get started
our first question is
what is the minimum volume of the sample
you need for this assay and can we add
sample directly to the strip or does the
sample need to be in scuse me need to be
in an in a micro plate
yeah so the minimum volume I would
recommend is hundred microliters I mean
you can go down to 75 micro liter but
hunter Michael it is an ideal volume to
do that as you don't have to do this in
a micro plate you can even you can have
a samples in it in any test tube in a
clean test tube or a micro centrifuge
tube and the question I think the other
question is can can we add sample
directly to the strip board does it have
to be no microvidia yeah I know people
who have been using the traditional the
lateral flow devices are used to adding
sample directly to the cassette based
situation where the strip is actually
inside a plastic cassette and the
catheter casing is not there in our case
so
indoors you can have a clean surface for
example like a para film or something or
the plastics of breeze and then you can
lay your strip on top of it and then you
can add in increments of 20 per
microliter and up to maximum how to
microliters you should see at is up just
fine
so dr. vadym is this essay compatible
with urea or
other teenager aiding agents such as SDS
so we posted a list of compatible
reagents and their maximum allowable
concentrations that could potentially
interfere with our ads for example I
guess des as the question is asked and
there is a second recommendation to be
within certain limits on something like
around 0.1% this year's and aggregate
number but I mean urea there is certain
concentration we also posted
concentrations for detergents like other
items like Pride and Li and also salt
concentrations how far can you on salt
sodium chloride and yeah I mean they're
a bunch of reagents that are commonly
used in protein extraction buffers we
listed them and we said you're going to
be within these concentrations to have
you know a non-interfering so that these
concentrations do not interfere the
assays and I mean I said in the
presentation if you dilute your sample
about tenfold most of the effects go
away so you don't have to worry about oh
what's there in my buffer because a lot
of times the these reagents are
proprietary for buying for a company you
don't even know they won't even tell you
exactly watch that the lysine buffer so
I would just tell you tenfold and make
sure it's roughly in the concentration
that is recommended that I was
mentioning earlier enough
detection limits and you define
all right so our next question is these
assays seem to be only qualitative any
plans to get them to quantify proteins
of interest
yeah you're right these are purely
qualitative yes or no at this point we
do not have a quantitation base database
but that certainly is of interest to us
we are looking into those assets as we
speak but these are designed to be very
extremely cheap and non and not so once
you talk quantitation you have to buy
instrumentation and you have to generate
some kind of a sine curve and it becomes
more complex so the idea of this asset
is extremely fast yes and now go to the
next step that's where this friction
and it looks like our next question is
why does the test-ban signal get weaker
as the concentration of sample increase
as in figure four
sometimes what happens is if we have
excess of analyze present in your sample
all of it cannot be conjugated with the
cold conjugated antibody present in the
conjugation pad which is the bottom of
the strip so what happens is the cone
and what I should call cold because it
is the cold antigen which is not
actually conjugated to the antibody
migrates and then it blocks all the test
signals on the on the T line so if your
concentration is in the right range of
the analyte is in the right range most
of the analyte will be bound by the
antibody which is conjugated cold and
these will ideally get arrested at the
cache line eager to see a signal so this
is something like a hook effect higher
concentrations usually give your weak
weaker signals so in those conditions I
I would recommend doing just one more
dilution of your sample about tenfold a
hundredfold and do one more time the
same assay is a signal completely
disappears which means there's not an
advantage in but as the ascetical
improves upon further dilution which
means this is not put into the linear
sample
so it looks like we have a time for just
a couple more questions the next
question is what about fusion proteins
is there any problem with these
um if I understand right fusion proteins
fusion to a tag I mean I'm not exactly
following the question here when you say
fusion proteins is here's the thing as
long as the tag present on your sample
remember these assays are designed to
detect
tags on the protein these tags are
listed in one of those slides can be
[Music]
purification of detection tags the
assets that we develop these for include
has a che flag
Mik v5 step back to GFC sumo MVP and
these tags as long as these sacs are
available it doesn't matter what else is
there in your protein and and you should
be able to detect these tags and your
proteins which means you are entirely
detecting that yes you expressed your
protein we detect these tags which are
present on your protein
so dr. vadym this is going to be our
last question what's the sensitivity of
the assay for his for this tag compared
to Western blot
um these are very sensitive I'm a
certain one of the experiments you can
detect in a in his tag again it depends
in Sebastian blood depends on what
antibody is talking about some
antibodies that really goes on and you
would be shot
not that good and of course Russian
blood takes the matter over night time
range of your life to do the entire
process equipment or everything these
Isis are designed to be very simple as
the guard sensitivity is concerned you
can detect a concentration in the range
of 10 microgram per ml of his tag put in
your samples very easily anything about
10 micrograms per ml you should be very
comfortable if you're in that range so
if in a Western blot you're talking
about 10 microgram per ml sample on a
Western probably can get a signal
with a 10 microgram pandemic each track
protein sample again depends on the
antibodies but I should say for any
competitions in assets in general that
are small tags is if you're black so on
so forth if you are in the range of a 10
microgram per ml you should be able to
detect your protein very easily that
should not be a problem again the
concentration that I'm referring to is a
concentration of actually that tagged
protein in your sample your samples
could be in the midst of kind of other
lysis proteins it doesn't matter but
your proteins this is the tag protein
should be in that range of concentration
which is 10 microgram primer
I would like to once again thank dr.
vadym for his presentation I would also
like to thank Thermo Fisher Scientific
for making today's educational webcast
possible before we go I want to let
everyone know that today's webcast will
be available for on-demand viewing
through September of 2019 please share
that with your colleagues who may have
missed today's live event that's all for
now thank you for joining us and we hope
to see you again soon goodbye